yeah welcome to this video five minute
game mmm sorry five minute game done
that seemed in English I'd actually
stays in English opening and now we
probably transpose to amarok see point
yep he allows me to play if I'm so its
amarok see now always like this opening
for white I never lost the game with it
and I mean of course long time control
of course I lost blitz games in this
opening but not not longer time controls
yeah White's ideas to build up a very
solid Center enjoy space advantage end
at some point maybe put up a knight on
d5 Wow 6q not sure raleigh six is a very
weakening move weakening a d6 enormously
actually i don't know what his answer to
see fibers he cannot take SD 7s hanging
and don't yeah this i can i can just
take
now that's between but I've got 96 96 is
a very very a very serious threat now
yeah should I just play Knight b6 it's
probably the easiest attacking the the
rook and forcing an exchange of Queens
just 22 rock d to the rook is so yeah
the rook must move and no gap it's got
got more than one but I think just just
taking us a good way to go he's
threatening on a two hmm yeah just just
play be three with knights on EA TANF a
term he cannot really do yet indeed
cannot really do anything spectacular I
just have worked you one next and then
possibly i'm an activation of my my
night here maybe Knight d4 yeah Knight
d4 looks looks fine this exchanges
probably yeah and now I've got a good
position of this official if he goes
rook da da play Bishop g5
yeah let's activate the king oh ok
question is Bishop c4 maybe yeah this
Bishop is not doing much at six exchange
it and maybe i'm wrong i'm able to go
night to do six if he exchanges yeah i
can he can go to f5 but this isn't
connected to connected to any great plan
this Bishop f5
it's actually interesting
yeah a problem should play here to cover
the rook 1944 stuff like that would
check so ok
hmm yes no one the snow already no clear
cut away to to win okay let's let's drop
this packet somehow not leading to much
he goes Rukia daigo King up to I need to
need to reposition my pieces here maybe
slightly improve it let's say be four we
should be three nights e46 is actually a
good plan yeah maybe do that don't don't
see much much that it can do
yeah h 30 g RG fri can actually
sacrifice on g4 Wow 97 okay 97 is
playing King to g8 okay well but what
what is this doing here there should be
five maybe well 96 is simply a simply
strong
there's a lot I now the rook f7f 50 ism
trying to to sacrifice is it better
maybe if I go to page six I screw you
one ok I just take the rook that should
be should be enough see fiber so
protected should Bishop to d5 maybe it
goes bishop CA d'Oro could be one and
then take b7
check
yeah this night on h5 is not exactly
helping wait just just a second I go
this go here I this is Rose's ok I get
the check and now the easiest is to take
and two now maybe route g1 intending
rook da made Bishop e7 I go see seven
threatening look the eight King bee 758
is also also decisive just promoting the
poor now black resigns you know I well
this 9886 was a very weird plan I mean
even might be five as some some
something to consider but this is strong
i mean how do you ever protect your
position here with g6 I really don't
understand the idea why why would you
give yourself such a very big porn this
is not a head shot or something I mean
the bishop is on g7 and it's very animal
yes position yeah alright thanks for
watching